[Music]
so here's my rant and i'll see you in
three years i don't care if you buy an
nft i just don't care
you've got your perspective
i just want to be happy don't you want
to be happy
hey this is the non-fungible podcast nfp
with your host d klein and today i have
a very special guest gary vee welcome to
the show
i really appreciate it thank you for
having me hey this is wild i have to
tell you i'm pretty excited about this i
really appreciate you making time for
this
thank you thank you for saying that and
flattered i'm really excited to be on it
honestly yeah i've noticed you're uh
making quite the deep dive into the
whole nft art scene the last couple of
days i've seen you all over the place i
saw you on crypto campfire the other day
tell me about uh you know it seems like
when you're doing something you just go
full bore at it
i really do and i really you know it's
funny people don't know this about me
because they see all the energy you know
what's so funny i think so much of the
energy that i bring has to do with the
fact that usually it's it's
because i've been pent up for three to
four months about something i'm excited
about right so for example
you know with sports cards which was
something similar that i got very
passionate about you know i grew up
passionate about it and then
i got very very passionate about it
about three years ago it was
it was several several months
uh maybe almost a year on that one that
i was doing real homework before i had
come out and said this that and the
other thing you know i've been doing
lightweight
homework you know since probably the
summer
you know i i on nfts
the reason i
bought
aetherium in 2016 after aaron battalion
big shout out tara battalion former cto
of living social great dc great
technologist
educated me on it at south by southwest
um
was
basically the understanding of the
potential of what became nfts like i was
like oh okay this isn't currency this is
framework build on you know like
platform and so
i think i get so loud and excited
because i've been wanting to
be loud and excited for months i i
basically do
60 70 of my knowledge base before i say
a word to the world
for example i've been doing that with vr
quite a bit i'm very deep into vr
more than people think because i never
talk about even this mention is already
a lot for me by my standards because i
don't
like to talk about things that i don't
know anything about now i don't mind to
be in this place where i'm like hey i
have some real
opinions and understandings and thoughts
and hypotheses
comma there's still a lot of things i
need to know
to
really feel comfortable the way i do
about social media or wine or sports
cards but i don't feel like i'll be
embarrassed i feel like i understand my
point of view on what the consumers are
going to do with nft i feel like i can
speak i can speak to erc20 and erc721
and i could speak to crypto punks and
larva labs and i could speak to pepe
being a btc a bitcoin version of like
like you know like i understand what
rapping is now you know like i can i can
i can hang enough where i'm not wasting
people's time because what i'm great at
according to my mother um but but in all
seriousness what i'm very comfortable
with is consumer behavior i mean
what i can say today is for example i
can say the following sentence to an
audience
you know i'm picking very specific
places i want to be on podcast i don't
have a lot of time i you know dk i do
this show because of the people
you
comma
the people that i anticipate listening
to this show which is a very
authentic og
thoughtful
bright kind community
it is
it's an awesome i know i do a lot of
homework so i feel very comfortable i
know who's listening right now which is
people i admire is what would be the
word i use comma what i think i bring to
the table
in 1995 when i went into dot com or
email or google adwords or youtube or
social or
everything i've done in my life
madison avenue startup land
i can bring things like hey everybody
listen
and i'm just incredibly comfortable to
put this on the record
nft over the next 12 to 18 months is
going to be very similar to ico yep
97 of these projects are going to
collapse in secondary value
it's going to confuse people say it was
a fad it was beanie babies
comma
the underlining tech and consumer
behavior
is going to be one of the most
significant things that happens in
modern technology i'm with you
cool so like you know i can relate yeah
yeah please please yeah
i don't want to take up too much time no
take it away the podcast but i have the
same experience when i learn about
bitcoin and ethereum i literally spent a
year learning about it before i did
anything about it and then i just
couldn't
contain myself anymore and i began
writing about it and that's how i got to
writing for cointelegraph
was just through blogging about it and
writing about it every day until the
point that people noticed my writing and
that's when last year i had the
opportunity to write about crypto art in
particular and especially about the
trash art movement
and that just flipped a switch for me
because i was like holy crap this is
marcel duchamp this is dada this is the
beginning of pop art it's the beginning
of modern art 100
uh it's a renaissance or a renaissance
of that same process yet now in a
digital realm and comma
those artists made peanuts
yeah in the scheme of the economics that
happened over the next 50 years the fact
that the jackson pollock of today
whoever she or he may be
his family will be collecting checks in
31 years
on a on a royalty rate on a transaction
makes my heart smile darren in a way
that you couldn't imagine yeah it's
amazing with that too
these same artists whereas before
they were the artists uh you know in the
the sloppy clothes with the you know
cheap
paint paint all over their clothes or
whatever and then there was the
collector and that was a different group
entirely you now have this mix like i
collect i collect art i i never really
collected her before in my life yeah and
now i collect it regularly um
do you do you tran do you transact on
art karen i do yes yeah i create art i
sell art i sell secondary do you buy our
and reach sell it at times if you just i
do yes this is the reason i asked that
is that's probably going to be the most
interesting thing in the super short
term for me
which is what is the
og community going to think about
what i know is coming which is an
enormous amount of collector flipper
trader at heart people who are going to
get much more enjoyment
of buying a piece of art and reselling
it than doing that with a stock than
doing that with a currency like for
example i have
the same feeling like for example the
art i have behind me elise bartlett
former employee i support
art from a friend standpoint mm-hmm
number one number number two personal
networks key networking it's just i'm
just i'm giving you like i am a baseball
card comic book
collectible toy flipper at heart i love
it i love buying uh
you know uh
a blue snaggle tooth that came from the
sears cantina set because that's the
rare snaggletooth and versus the red
suit and buying that at a garage sale
for four bucks and selling it on ebay
for 200 bucks or buying it for 100 bucks
and selling it for 200 bucks later
because i thought
it was a down time for star wars really
i enjoy that i don't like stock market i
don't enjoy buying a stock and then
reselling it no enjoyment i love flea
market garage sales sports cards culture
well let me encourage you then to look
into
where that really happens because of
course you can go to the nifty gateway
you can go i do i do have work on known
origin for example however i didn't
start unknown origin of course right i
started on wearable i know where it
started on on openc
right and that's where you can get that
garage sale type 100 percent where did
you find that gem right i super rare
open c wearable like bitsky i i'm
watching everything
i'm watching everything and right now
i'm just very fascinated because i think
there's a huge amount of humans on earth
that share my dna that nobody
talks about which is the following
that trading component is much more fun
in nfts than it is in real estate or
wall street
number two
and this is where it gets really
interesting for me
this is a real thing that i've been
doing my whole life you gotta tokenize
those
are you kidding me it's like the thing
that keeps me up at night i'm like oh my
god
in grammar school kindergarten first
grade third grade sixth grade a lot of
kids knew me as a doodler as those
people who thought it was gonna be that
i was gonna be an artist
which
never gets talked about in my narrative
not something i share and you have to
watch my vlogs very carefully and you'll
see that i'm doodling a lot in meetings
right so
when this all hit my radar
you know
that was something that really got me
emotional i'm like oh my god is this
going to be
like
wow god literally this is something i
said god thank you it's literally
something i said to myself six months
ago god
are you kidding me have you created a
technology that takes everything that i
am
how to build a community
you know understanding storytelling
the doodling component the garage sale
flipping the cabbage the garbage pail
kit like it this is crazy this is like
my life's work so i've been very
cautious
and thoughtful of my entry into this
world
because i don't want to i know i have a
big platform now i'm not who i was the
first couple times you know
i
i
definitely um
i definitely
am worried to drive the market
right i'm incredibly scared of that
darren
i'm scared to talk scared of creating a
bubble is that what you mean
you know it's funny i'm actually not
because i think i'm only gonna buy and
talk about things that i've decided are
30-year projects okay so i'm actually
not scared because i think i'm good it's
what happened in sports cards in the
sports cards world
i've been uncomfortably right
and it's because i'm really darn good at
this and and so i'm talking about nft as
a
genre i'm not really talking about
projects
because i just have more homework to do
i've you know i've alluded to so i'll do
it here as well i have decided that
crypto punks is a 30-year project
um and there's been a million articles
and this audience doesn't need me to
explain why so i won't spend time on
that but
no i'm i'm worried about being perceived
as pumping and dumping as creating and
so it's i got to really be thoughtful of
how i'm going to navigate but i'm not
actually scared about the bubble i am
probably scared about the macro bubble
like when
when the inevitable [ __ ] hits the fan
with all these projects
i do think everything gets dragged down
with it
so i am scared to tell friends to invest
in things or right because even though i
think punk's
is a steal
do i think if in nine months or 13
months or 16 months there's that crater
moment because there's just too much
supply and there's not sustainability of
the secondary demand
could it go down with it i do do i think
that's probably one i'll go most buying
crazy
to me it's april 2000 there april 2000
is when the stock market collapsed
internet stocks
and everybody bailed on the internet
itself and that's when i tripled down on
the internet and said no no the stocks
might have been overvalued but the whole
genre is going nowhere
yeah and that was when i bought my
amazon stock for the first time because
i was like and so like that's what i'll
do with nfts when and if when and if
because just because i think it might it
may not
but if it does have that moment that's
probably when i'll go shopping the most
on the things that i've deemed most
meaningful but there's so much i mean
different blockchains and you know right
you know ethereum flow
there's so much going on there different
there'll be many more does ethereum
scale wrapping things burning things
like i'm you know there's a lot to think
through this is early early early days
yeah absolutely what are your thoughts
on trash art have you looked that looked
at that at all
not deeply yet i'm still in the phase
where
because i decided punks was real that i
spend an ungodly amount of time
educating myself there
and i'm continuously spending most of my
time doing stuff like this whether in
private or public i want to become
friends with people in the community i
want to offer my value to them i want to
meet them and i'm still learning so i
haven't gone
you know i've done very surface level
stuff with like hash masks with crypto
you know kitties i've looked at a little
bit for my own education because that
was obviously like many the first thing
i've looked at top shot carefully i've
looked at
a lot of the wax stuff because i like
street fighter and garbage pill kids
um
i've looked at you know i've done my
homework on people so i've done a little
on the individual artist front
artifacts so you know the bitsky
projects i've looked at stuff
i've done my random like three hour deep
dives into open c and nifty just to poke
around
but i haven't yet on uh tragic i'm
excited to and i will probably one of
the best places to look for that is the
artist that i interviewed for that piece
that i wrote about it called immutable
trash you can send me that link after
this i'll read it over the weekend yeah
for sure his name is robness he's
probably the best known
trash artist along with max osiris and
of course following that there's a huge
movement of more artists that join in
with that
and i actually sent you the link to it
in your twitter if you want to peek at
it but a bit of a read to do during a
conversation obviously yeah i'm not
going to do that i want to focus on this
it's practical um but those two stand
out another great place to go if you
want to find out more about
just that entire movement and community
building
is uh the art gallery auction house on
telegram daniel penn i think crypto
campfire mentioned them too actually
that was actually where i found a home
when i began this as an artist because
i'm coming from a different world um i'm
a teacher
i teach full-time
i began writing because i just love
writing
and from that i just
when i saw the crypto arts i was just
like felt like what you were saying
where it's like all these different
things i love
just came together into this one
i can't stop thinking about like i'm
obsessed listen i'm obsessed with
esports i'm obsessed with the cannabis
industry i grew up in the wine business
i don't smoke but i'm fascinated
i
i'm obsessed with many micro things
things have happened so many things have
happened but i've not felt anything like
this since 2005 when i was like oh the
internet's about to make a big change
this social media thing this is a real
thing this is a third wave here yeah
this yeah that's right i feel like for
me it's 95.05 i'm kind of mad that it's
not 2015 because they're going to be a
nice round numbers but it's 0.5 9 you
know it's 95.05 it's probably some
fibonacci thing or something yeah
probably uh but uh
god damn it's exciting and like the and
the fact that i get to bleed in my
collecting flipping
like
like pop culture ip
retro oh [ __ ] it's just so exciting yeah
if it goes beyond that right like i mean
people get excited about the money right
and of course the money is great like
the fact that a person like me to me
it's not the money it's the being right
i love being right i love being right
like no but really it's like and by the
way i don't want to be right so i can
tell people i'm right it's like a weird
game with my game i'm winning the game
am i right is this kid it's true and i
love it when people are like nah
and then you know two years later it's
like
that's everything to me that the other
you know you you may know this because
you have a little context for me it's
why i love documenting i love you know
when when someone's like oh gary you're
fly by night and i can show him my point
of view on virtual goods in 2010 i don't
know if you saw that clip i don't know
if you could all fly by night at this
point anymore yeah but you know what
like
when when uh not fly by night you know
what people are like oh you're just
jumping on this
you don't care about nfts yeah and i'm
like look at this video in 2010 when i'm
talking about virtual currency and
virtual goods like this has been on my
mind in some shape or form for a very
very long time
it's just prime time it's a culmination
of a number of different elements coming
together you know coalescing absolutely
you know and but with that what i was
saying was the money's great like it's
it's amazing i was talking to someone
just the other day who i forget which
country he lives in who's a developing
country
and he says to me this art that i sold
i'm paying my kids school fees with it
like
this is like life-changing game changing
i know somebody who sold a hash mask in
india to a big collector that is like
more money than his parents have made in
five years
yeah next level yeah
you know the opportunities are huge but
beyond that too it's this
community and that's maybe a little
harder to see with you know the hash
masks and the the crypto punks but if
when you get down into the dirt of it as
i have as an artist starting that like
like someone i just sold my first piece
the other day it was terrible it was i
just took a bitcoin logo and i put it
into an app called photomosh and it
melted it and made it look like a fried
egg and i called it fried bitcoin right
and a guy was like hey is that your
first piece i want that right and
it's a great feeling right it's an
intense feeling for me what's been
interesting about this
is thinking through the metadata
[Music]
so i
my project is going to be very very
interesting okay and i don't want to
give too much away but i want to give
you a little something
for our history we'll look back at one
day very interesting
i'm assuming in your case you've got
people
facilitating this process
when you say facilitating
what i mean is getting everything set up
getting everything tokenized getting you
know
if you're going beyond that if you're
doing something with smart contract
technology and stuff like that i'm
talking to people and trying to figure
out where i want to do this and how i
want to do this
when
when but what's fascinating is the
reason i asked you when you say
you know facilitating i am gonna draw
all five thousand five hundred
fifty-five right well that's a that's a
good point to make it's not like
something yeah exactly people have
jumped in with hiring some artists and
then correct i am going to i am gonna
create the stories the dynamics and the
concepts the pipes and doing it right
and getting it minted and getting it
smart contract properly yes i'm i'm
speaking to all the a lot of people in
the community and trying to figure out
who the right things are so you said
5500 pictures that you said yeah i'm
already giving too much so we'll talk
about it
we'll
edit that out
seriously
no no it's okay you can keep it but i
want you to have the scoop but like
don't don't play it up too much
hopefully it's just an easter egg in the
long run it'll be in the tweet yeah 50
500
but you know it's it's um i'm really
excited i'm excited i'm excited i feel
like i know when i find my home i know
when i'm
the sports car community my home the
wine community my home the
entrepreneurial community at home this
is going to be a home and and and a home
that
is going to show a different side of me
from a creativity standpoint that has
always been there i've spoken so much
about the creativity of being an actual
entrepreneur but
this one's really going to be obvious
and i'm going to enjoy it and it's going
to open up a whole new
avenue to my life which i can just feel
incredibly excited about
yeah it's just an opportunity to be
expressive in a different way right i
also hope i motivate people you know i
think i've got a lot of eyes on me i
have a communication style that lands
for
certain amounts of people and i feel
like somebody's going to say wait a
minute am i an artist too and is going
to fulfill their destiny of being an art
i i think what nft what what social
media did was allowed people to be
personalities and experts that would
have never been that
influencer marketing influencers have
been
are is now a collection of people who
are destined to be lawyers but are now
known for yoga
accountants that are now known for star
trek and i think nft infrastructure is
going to allow somebody who is destined
to be a carpenter actually now to be an
artist someone who's destined to be a
sports agent now to be an artist
somebody that was destined to be a
stay-at-home dad now to be a artist
somebody that was destined to be a
police officer to now be a meaningful
artist
the fact that art will now be practical
to a generation of parents
and encouraged instead of discouraged is
going to be a very good thing for
society and i'm excited to see the birth
of it
it's yeah it's fascinating you know it
makes me think about i was actually just
talking to someone about this today the
idea that you know we're talking right
now about art nfts but in my mind i'm
anticipating
pretty much anything that is property
at some point you could theoretically
say could that be tokenized well that's
that's a foregone conclusion to your
point i think my passion
right now sit around creativity but for
example
every book
by any author that's got any juice
is gonna be launched as an nft
like i've got to rethink my entire
thought process of signing another book
deal
why would i do that
i can launch as an nft make incredible
dynamics
deliver the actual book on the back of
the nft
create incredible secondary market
dynamics i mean the world darren this is
a big [ __ ] deal it is i'm gonna sell
my i've been trying to tell people this
for two years well you've been right
good news you know how you like being
right good news there you go
this is going to change everything caps
absolutely everything i think
what's going to be what i would
encourage everybody here
who's listening to fall into something i
said the other night and i'm i'm using
it i like it don't try to convince
have conviction and it's very different
you know
convincing people
is
is
fun
but exhausting and not required when
you're this right
so like people like gary convince me
about and if this literally actually
ironically happened today
somebody said convince me about this
space i'm like i'm not going to here's
the here's how i'm going to convince you
this nft thing is going to be one of the
biggest technology shifts in your life
i'll see you in three years i'm not
going to sit here and try to explain to
you
that you don't understand social
currency human behavior
why people wear logos on their clothes
what happens in a digitized world
why people will be curious like
rubbernecking and reality tv and social
media to know what people have bought
and ledgered that the provenance matters
incredibly and always has in our society
that eliminating the middle that brings
very little value is a good idea and the
internet's been doing it technology's
been doing that for for its entirety as
a term like i'm not gonna do that for
you i don't need to do that for you it's
just gonna play out why did why did
chiefs and indians and cavemen paint
their faces with colors and have skins
that were like this has been going on
this is a foregone conclusion so here's
my rant and i'll see you in three years
i don't care if you buy an nft i just
don't care
yeah i mean speaking of provenance i
think really interesting element of that
a lot of people don't recognize is you
know say for you look at this top shot
thing right and you think about okay
well
whose hands has this particular card
been in so cool and you can look back
and go whoa this was actually in lebron
james wallet for example really matters
people don't understand that's going to
be really cool when you meet somebody in
13 years
at an event
instead of going to google or instagram
like many do now i think people will go
to public wallets and look at
what they've done and i'll be like oh
darren you were [ __ ] on this blah
blah blah like you know people love to
have street cred they're like i knew
about pantera first like vanilla
yeah exactly or like i was early like
for me i was early on notorious b.i.g
but do i really have proof i don't but i
could
i could you could you know like where
you know when someone's like i was early
on nirvana were you
like now you have but now in 35 years
somebody who's early on
something
is likely gonna have
some proof to it because though that
that entity the band the influencer of
the person the thing is going to have an
nft infrastructure that's going to prove
could do you understand the level of
clout darren
that somebody could have as being the
first person to buy the first item that
pearl jam put out in 1991
if you could prove it yeah well guess
what that's the world we're about to go
into that's right
irrefutably
irrefutably so i think prominence is
going to be a currency that matters in
an insane way i think people are naive i
told people that online dating would be
the standard in 2000 they laughed at me
i said that people would buy wine on the
internet in 1995 they laughed at me
i told people that they would spend all
their time on facebook they laughed at
me playing mobile games they laughed
then like all i do is get laughed at
and that's when i know i'm on to
something and this one is one that's
making a lot of people laugh they're
like i'll just take a screenshot what's
the difference of like everything well i
was talking uh fine art with uh sasha
bailey he's the founder of my babe
and uh he was talking about how he had
experience with traditional fine art for
example if you were to say look at an
andy warhol and it was the real one andy
warhol and then you had a fake sitting
next to it they are indistinguishable
you cannot tell the difference between
them
you know and
that's a problem so what do they do they
go by providence they go okay whose
hands were
who had this piece you know where is the
history of this piece and again that's
where the blockchain is
vastly superior as a solution it's not
even close right not only that where are
those andy warhols they're in a vault no
one's even looking at the things correct
i go to the new york met i don't know if
you saw that but yeah i posted about it
i go to the met
and i go look at a painting and i'm like
is this even the real painting or did
they just put a replica here because
they don't want the real one to get
damaged
correct
and meanwhile somebody changes their
profile pick to a crypto punk
and you can go check if they're the
actual owner of it you could you can you
could
and then you get into the monetization
of the ip like you look at some of the
nft standards where you're allowed to
monetize something you buy up to a
hundred thousand like there's so much
neat stuff
it's just gonna be neat that's like the
word like i've been using the word neat
like like i don't know if it brings me
back to it's a childish nostalgic thing
right
it's neat
it's [ __ ] neat well that's why i'm
making the art for myself as well
a lot of the art i make literally makes
me laugh as i'm making it good you know
like there's a joy
in it and i'm hoping you have the same
experience with your doodling i mean
it's are you kidding me joy in it right
i mean
look at patient pig
that's right you know like i
i
couldn't be more excited
to be a part of this
i
am really happy that i've been able to
bring a lot of awareness i've had a lot
of beautiful dms and things like you
know i have a big platform and i'm able
to bring awareness to people the
flamingo project or you know voracious
or you know whatever it might be like
it's just really fun
let's talk barriers though let's talk
problems please
you know what you know ethereum
obviously you know if you're minting on
ethereum like
it's got some technological problems
clearly you know it it's it's a it's uh
too much success
yep gas is expensive gas is terrible you
know uh we had kind of a mini crypto
winter in the art
scene where i don't know you talked
about that you've been following it for
months and it was just on fire in
october november
come december ethereum prices kind of
skyrocketed and all of a sudden
people couldn't create or they could
create but they couldn't mint they
couldn't tokenize unless they were
upper echelon
you know where do you see that going
too early for me to make a call that i
would want to look back on and say okay
you were smart or you're an idiot i just
don't know that's the honest truth
um
i know human dynamics so what i mean by
that
i know that there's an incredible amount
of people that are building on top of
ethereum that the network is so vast
that the stakes are so collectively high
that people
that are dramatically more technically
skilled than i are tackling it
at
ferocious levels now i do think that
people are naive a little bit with l2
and all that like i think there is some
naivete because when you want it to
happen
you know i'm thinking a lot about
the burning and wrapping of tokens you
know like what listen i would never have
bought crypto punks if i didn't know
what rapping was right because i would
have been too scared
like you know
i you know they're very different
technologies but there was a day where
yahoo was the only search engine
sure and then google came along and i
sit here and say well
there could be a different blockchain
like like like like
jeeves
correct so i mean look how great flow is
rohan you know learned a lot
being on on kitties and the scalable
issues and
you know flow and there's tons there's
tons of innovation going on on this so
uh
ethereum scaling issues scare me less
than they did six months ago
because i have an enough
belief that if it doesn't it doesn't
mean all the assets go to zero
right
and
i'm a person that
doesn't have the skill set nor to be
honest the interest
on how the concrete and steel is made
i like designing the room
got it so i try to stay educated enough
that i can speak to the way i'm speaking
to you or i'm dangerous right i can be a
little dangerous but i'm not the person
that's going to speak about the
technical underpinnings at the level
that so many others can what i spend my
passion and time and skill set on is the
human dynamics on top of those things
now i don't want to get caught with my
pants down which is why i try to stay
knowledgeable-ish
but to speak about scalability of
ethereum that is above my pay grade
i kind of anticipate in my opinion that
we'll get to a point where there's a
level of interoperability
that you know perhaps these tokens are
moving from one chain to another i mean
that's obviously a technical challenge
now i i think that that is
something that is in the best interest
of everyone thus makes me think
likely
well on the flip side you could say well
maybe it's more like the betamax vhs
situation where vhs dominated because it
simply was the one that was more widely
used
and you know you could make that
argument for ethereum
i think you could
but the speed of
technology advancements are so different
today compared to what it would have
taken for a third
you know cool but that was a one-on-one
battle
if the speed and cost associated with
innovating back then
in that game
might have led to something called ps9
which would have destroyed vhs
sure and i think that's how i look at uh
flow had the luxury of knowing what
ethereum was
right
yup
what do you think of the whole you know
kind of there's these you know kind of
uh curated scenes for galleries and then
there's the ones that are kind of wide
open like where do you find yourself
drawn to the most
neither and both
to me to me both will succeed
of whomever wins
right so
you will have meaningful players in both
okay
and then i think you'll have
underlining technology
where people like myself and others can
do it on their own domain and just have
the underpinnings of the capabilities
within it
let's bring into your background a
little bit here what what do you think
it is about this you know you talked
about it a bit already but you know you
talked about your childhood what is it
about your childhood like that really
clicks with this you think that's a
great question you know my mother's side
of the family has a very heavy
leaning towards
storytelling they're just like funny
russian uncles who get drunk and
storytelling story tell and i'm like
okay that's something
being an immigrant and learning how to
speak english by watching
scooby-doo
batman the
adam west stuff and the hulk the movie
stuff you know the tv stuff tv show
dukes of hazzard like a lot of 70s and
80s ip taught me how to speak the
language and i think cemented
my americana
you know um
being a merchant trader
you know
i think this is just the modern
stones and rubies and you know like gold
i would have probably been a great
character in the gold rush
you know and so
dna and circumstance
of like i do think the immigrant can't
speak english these are the things that
taught me english and they're all ip
probably has something to do with it i
can't really unwrap it sweet pickles but
there's a comfort you find in that
innocence yeah yeah for sure and then i
maintained it like i loved garage
sailing my whole life and buying toys
and books and
mugs and t-shirts of ip happy days more
mork and mindy like i just always
gravitated to nostalgia americana
ip
that [ __ ] yeah yeah
very interesting different question
entirely totally uh kind of a
bit of a shift here you know i think a
lot about how
this will change the way economies work
on a kind of a macro scale
you know um
any thoughts on that in regards to you
know big time uh you know
kind of changing
i think i will become a central bank
i think humans will have economies built
around them because of access and
metadata
[Music]
how does that work in our current system
without there being a huge conflict
or is that inevitable
i mean if you're going super macro with
me around like cryptocurrency and nfts
versus
you know sovereign nations like say fiat
money versus oh i think it's a i think
it's a big big deal yeah
i think that there's inevitable
regulation
that
is overbearing
and it will depend on how big the
movement is at the time
to see what the counter reaction is i
mean i think the stakes are high if you
believe that bitcoin wins
then you believe in
the
massive lack of leverage
of sovereign nations
or that they just rush in and they try
to have their own little hash war going
on and try to stop going too much as
they can right if they aren't going to
do it i mean germany i feel like is my
prediction to go first like i think oh
they're gonna
why terms
by the way when i say complete intuitive
wild guess
of like
i always think about who's incentivized
but big enough
um see because i would lean towards say
something like say iran or something
like that
they already kind of have their own
control if you think about it if you
think of germany as a major player in
europe where europe is now kind of like
a third player in the world behind the
us and china
it's almost like they're incentivized to
do a move to almost like re-energize
you know because don't forget that's the
part of the world that was number one
and i always think there's some
underlining tension when you lose your
spot i think america losing to china
in that global leader over the next
hundred years will be like an
interesting underlining resentment the
way that london and germany look at the
us
and so i don't know i've always had this
weird feeling in my own game of chess in
my head that if there was a place that
would do this first and most meaningful
but that was big enough to actually
matter
so that's always been my hot guess are
they competent enough to fight it i
don't know
i genuinely don't know i often wonder i
just know i just see attraction i just
light systems i just know that to get
installed in my neighborhood i don't
know yeah
well that
that is a really good point
in in reality no in uh passing a law
that makes things illegal that would
make our head spin yes
[Music]
well that can cause harm i don't know if
it stops
i don't think it can be stopped
yeah i think you're probably right i
think it's like alcohol
you can do prohibition but be prepared
for the ramifications
and be prepared for people to still be
consuming alcohol correct
yeah uh talk about your hopes i mean you
didn't couldn't give a lot of detail
there about your project but you know
what do you see what are you hoping
happening here over the next year here
with your experience in the nft world
with your experience in nft art what are
you hoping to see
happen by far my reaction to that
question is
the 13 to 27 relationships i make in
this next year
that mirror the ones i made in 2006 like
the kevin rose's and the msgs and the
travis and the soccers and dave moran's
and
you know
just these real friendships
like you know lazarus and
belski like
these real real real friendships i think
i'm gonna make some of my best friends
in my life
over the next year
that's awesome i know for myself you
know just joining this community i've
made some
awesome friends that
you know we connect on our daily basis
you know this is going to be
a year that i make some best friends
that's awesome
uh anything any last words you want to
wrap up with i know you're kind of tight
on time i'm guessing you're a pretty
busy guy so yes i definitely appreciate
it i can definitely uh then i'm grateful
that i'm available that i'm
intellectually generous
i'm i'm so i was so gifted with the
ability to get mine that i always that
i'm a person that believes in like
abundance
so if there's anything i can be a help
to anybody
i think everyone can win
um
and uh and to be thoughtful on the
investing side i do think people need to
be very careful there's gonna be a
trillion projects and there's only so
much demand and right now a lot of the
demand is from people that are
financially incentivized they don't
really care about it they're going to
buy this thing because they think in a
week it's going to be this much
and that's okay i don't judge that i'm
an entrepreneur i'm a capitalist
you know in the good sense of the world
meaning i want it to be fair that's why
i love a lot about this i think it's
pure capitalism like there's it actually
a game of who is good not let's rig the
game
um and so
it's a meritocracy yeah it's a
meritocracy that's such a good point uh
i just would tell people like be
thoughtful because when it hits when it
crashes or goes down
you know it'll hurt it'll be fast it'll
be hard to liquidate there's not enough
underlying
demand to carry what's going on and so
you have speculation at scale
um
buy what you like
or
really do homework on things you
genuinely believe
are going to work for example every
great ip darren that's about to come out
whether it's star wars or star trek or
health or
smurfs or
whatever right i'm gonna look very
carefully on how they built it
you know because
i can't just say oh the pokemon thing's
going to crush because it's pokemon if
it's sloppy
and not thoughtful the dynamics won't
play out to make it a good quote-unquote
investment
yeah yeah well then you just have a
repeat of the ico
this is going to be a massive ico moment
just so you know this will be
that the [ __ ] coin like reality is there
is going to be an ungodly amount of nfts
that sell for a lot in the first three
months and go to
very small places so be very
pay very close attention to who's behind
it for example for me
what i'm going to do is going to be with
me to the day i die which gives me
tremendous confidence in the economics
around that ecosystem back to economies
around people
unfortunately i think a lot of people
that have my leverage of awareness and
audience i think are gonna go for the
quick three four five million dollar
score
and i think that's gonna hurt them and
it's definitely gonna hurt their fans
and i caution people to be thoughtful as
they continue to
navigate especially these next 24 months
but these next 24 years and nft are
going to be remarkable yeah 100
hey i really appreciate you taking this
time and i'm looking forward to your
podcast i hear you're doing it with
someone else in my community next week
now i don't want to give away too much
about that yet because i'm not sure if
he's even said
but um i'm excited to hear that as well
and i really appreciate you taking the
time to do this i mean of all the things
you could be doing with your time right
now why is it that you know this is what
you're doing i'm curious
i like people that are authentic to the
thing that i'm excited about hmm
that's awesome to be a lot of fancy
people who are going to hit me it's
already happened there's gonna be a lot
of super famous super wealthy super
leveraged super strategic people
uh there's all the natural people that
i'm friends with that are also in and
those are real relationships but there's
something
important to me that if i go into
someone's home i want to and they and
the rules are take your shoes off i want
to take them off said that somewhere
else the other day and it kind of feels
that way to me i want real friendships
real relationships i want to be in this
community for the rest of my life and
the only way i know how to do that is to
be is to bring value i know
that
in real life that my appearance on your
podcast for you gives you leverage
to do more with your podcast and i want
that for you
i appreciate that and the number one
asset that i can the number one asset i
protect is time
so to me
writing a being a 5 000 sponsor of your
podcast
is a hell
of a lot less
meaningful
of like me knowing the truth than me
allocating this time
right on instagram that's uh i'd be okay
with that too
you can have that comment too anyway my
friend thank you for your time i gotta
run right on thank you very much thank
you so much i'll see you in the circles
i hope to spend real time in person as
well awesome thank you sir where do you
live i live in alberta canada love it
love it actually uh
i love new york though i had tickets
booked i had hotel booked i had tickets
for hamilton booked ugh
i was already with my wife to come out
there for a week we'll be going to a lot
of conferences so i'm sure we'll be
seeing oh man
crushed but cheers take care thank you
youtube watcher what's up it's garyvee
first of all thank you so much i hope
you're doing super well during these
times i also want to ask you please
subscribe because my commitment and
exploration of youtube is about to
explode stories polls more content more
engagement more surprise and delight
this is the time to subscribe i hope you
consider it and i hope i see you soon
you